if you want to sound smart and be
perceived as more confident and more
intelligent than my God this video is
for you I'm gonna break down one of the
most controversial TED Talks I've seen
on how to sound more intelligent it has
13 million views on YouTube alone and
it's by a man named will Stephen and
it's controversial because he breaks
down how do you sound smart
when you don't have anything smart to
say and that's quite controversial but
it's interesting to study because if
there is a way if there is a way to
sound intelligent to be perceived as
more confident just by using your voice
your body and the way in which you speak
that's a superpower that means you can
carry that confidence and carry that
Dynamic way of speaking anywhere you go
regardless of how prepared you feel
regardless of how confident you may feel
on on inside so this video is about six
minutes it's one of my favorite TED
Talks because it's a real conversation
starter and we're gonna break down all
the ingredients for how you can be
perceived as more confident and more
intelligent sit back and let's watch it
together
hear that
that's nothing
which is what I as a speaker at today's
conference have for you all
I have nothing
nada
zip
zilch
Zippo
nothing smart nothing inspirational
nothing even remotely researched at all
I have absolutely nothing to say
whatsoever
and yet through my manner of speaking I
will make it seem like I do
hmm like what I am saying is brilliant
and maybe just maybe you will feel like
you've learned something
so already you might notice just this so
musical so so much Variety in his voice
and the way he goes up and down see if
you can listen for it
now I'm gonna get started with the
opening I'm going to make a lot of hand
gestures I'm going to do this with my
right hand I'm gonna do
adjust my glasses
and then I'm going to ask you all a
question by show of hands how many of
you all have been asked a question
before
okay great I'm seeing some hands and
again I have nothing here
thank you
now I'm going to react to that and act
like I'm telling you a personal anecdote
something to break the tension
something to endear myself a little bit
something kind of
embarrassing
embarrassing he's so good at at being
himself he's I think he's tapped into
something where he just I don't know he
seems so natural to me
and you guys are gonna make an awe sound
it's true it really happened
and now I'm going to bring it to a
broader point I'm going to reel you back
in
I'm gonna make it intellectual
I'm going to bring it to this man right
here
now
what this man did was important I'm sure
but I for one have no idea who he is
I simply Google image the word scientist
and now you see I'd like it to seem like
I'm making points building an argument
inspiring you to change your life when
in reality this is just me
buying
time now oh I love this me
buying time he has a way of melodic
speaking and just notice how many
different variations he has when he
speaks he's he's like a master of
musicality if you don't believe me let's
take a look at the numbers this is a
real thing that's happening right now
the number of talks that I'm giving is
one
interesting facts imparted thus far in
said talk well that's going to be a zero
my height in inches is 70.5 not the 0.5
there 2 times 6 equals 12 and then
interestingly enough 6 times 2 also
equals 12. that's math always always
doing humor 352 is a three digit number
one two three four five and then almost
immediately following that we get six
seven eight nine ten
now to add more filler here I'm going to
give you a couple more numbers to
consider uh 18.
237. wow
2.6 million million four four twenty
four staggering
these are real numbers all of them
and to follow that up let's take a look
at some graphs now if you take a look at
this pie chart what you're going to see
is that the majority far exceeds the
minority yeah
everybody see that
cool isn't it and let's take a look at
this bar graph because it shows
similarly irrelevant data now I'm doing
this because I'd like to make it seem
like I've done my homework if you were
say watching this on YouTube with the
sound off you might think huh okay
this guy knows what he's talking about
but I don't
know I'm floundering panicking I've got
nothing I'm a total and utter phony well
he's he is and he is and he's definitely
is prepared for this talk and he knows
exactly what he's doing but his broader
point is that even with the sound off he
appears like somebody that is confident
in what's happening right now and that's
a really powerful mindset to have and
the way that will is able to carry
himself and really just Express emotion
in his words to really
just own it that's the theme that I'm
noticing is will just owns what he says
and we can't help but feel like he knows
his stuff but you know what
what I was offered a TED Talk
and damn it I'm gonna see it through
now if you take a look behind me these
are just words paired with vaguely
thought provoking stock photos
I'm gonna point at them like I'm making
use both of my time as well as your time
but in reality I don't know what half of
them mean
and now as these continue I'm just going
to start saying gibberish
Gabba Gabba turkey now he's just mouth
in a mouth
trip my dog skip
rip it and dip it Richard
I'm an itty bitty baby bopper and I'm
hungry in my tum tum but what's
interesting about this whether it's your
humor or not is he just continues to
stay in character he he's showing that
it's not what he's saying it's how he is
owning the stage and you could even see
it in the way that he walks like he's
got a Swagger to him albeit it's his own
style he he knows what he's doing and
it's a brilliant way to illustrate
just how to appear more intelligent than
what you're actually saying we'll talk
about if this is a good thing or not but
let's finish this
Brad Pitt
Uma Thurman
names things words words and more things
and see it feels like it might make
sense doesn't it
like maybe just maybe I'm building to
some sort of satisfying conclusion I
mean I'm just stipulating as though I am
I'm pacing I'm growing in intensity I'm
taking off my glasses which by the way
are just frames
[Laughter]
I forgot about that
I wore them to look smart even though my
vision
is perfect
wow
and I'm gonna slow things down a little
bit
I'm gonna change the tone
I'm gonna make it seem like I'm building
[Music]
to a moment notice the pause
and what if I was
amazing isn't it what can you do life's
a roller coaster
if there's one thing you take away from
my talk I'd like you to think about what
you heard at the beginning
and I'd like you to think about what you
hear now
because it was nothing
and it's still nothing think about that
or don't that's fine
and now I'm going to stop talking thank
you great job Stephen what a brilliant
way to illustrate an idea without
pointing it out explicitly
I think this is an excellent example of
how to
how to be perceived as Confident by
really I don't think he's manufacturing
confidence I think he genuinely has this
inner feeling of certainty about
everything that's happening and he's
able to take that energy and channel it
into his words that's why he could say
the word for
454 he could say it as if it meant
something important but it doesn't but
the ability to say it in a way that it
does is something that's totally within
our control all of us can access
conviction all of us can access
confidence and all of us can speak with
musicality I mean just how expressive he
was in his pacing and gestures and
variety with his voice it's not one
thing it's just dynamism and if you want
to study that dynamism there's no better
place than Ultra speaking because we've
broken it down into games games like
conductor games like rapid fire
analogies games that train you to speak
with energy
and practice speaking with confidence in
moments where you don't feel it because
if you're able to turn on your
confidence switch on command then the
higher you go up in leadership
the better you're gonna get even when
you don't have time to prepare even when
you can't go into all of the details of
any single meeting you'll be able to
have a confidence that doesn't depend on
content doesn't depend on Preparation a
confidence that can that can stay with
you when you need it most and it's
totally something that you have access
to within and hopefully Ultra speaking
can help unlock it for you even more
that's what the mission is here and if
you're on this channel then I hope you
get one step closer to being a
self-expressed confident human being who
loves to speak
thanks so much for watching I'll see you
in the next video